at first we were told they weren't
needed
then they became law now face coverings
will largely be
a personal choice in england from monday
a breath of fresh air for some but not
everyone
is ready to ditch the mask i think it's
far too soon yeah
or too soon yeah because i mean the
the infections are going up the deaths
are going up
it just seems the wrong time altogether
i think i will continue to do whatever
protects the majority
of the population and probably wales and
scotland are more sensible
in their approach to continuing wearing
face masks the only change i'll probably
make is in the pub you can be able to
i'm looking forward to actually going up
to the bar and asking for a point table
service is great but
the british audition to stand at the bar
and have a point with your friends
the government says it'll be down to
businesses to decide whether customers
need to continue to wear a face mask or
not
at bristol central salon there's no
intention
of relaxing the rule i feel that we've
spent the last
year making the salon very coped safe
for
our staff and clients i think that
people
aren't ready to take that risk and to
come into a very close contact service
with no mass no screens or anything else
at the moment
but it's a different story one mile down
the road at the avon
packet after months of having to enforce
the rule
landlord steve can't wait to get rid of
the sign
i'm elated about it you know because it
gives everybody the fair opportunity
to get back to normal living his plan
for monday
stand in the borough have a drink and
enjoy yourself loves about enjoyment
let's get on and enjoy it masks may be
off in
england but scotland and wales are
keeping them mandatory
which brings a further complication
especially
for commuters as they start to head back
to the office
for instance those traveling from here
in bristol to cardiff
will have to cover up when they cross
the border into wales
the train companies say they'll be
making special announcements to remind
travellers
their legal obligation i'll probably
just take it off you know if it's like
this you know there's not many people
i suppose it's all a confidence thing as
soon as i feel confident that
if you like things are safer then yes i
will take it off but
it's funny what this pandemic's done
it's got in your brain
it's that cautious attitude the
government hopes people will
adopt and while some will embrace the
freedom
it seems most will keep covered for some
time to come
dan whitehead sky news in bristol